at exactly 3 45 pm on september 9 1947
grace hopper discovered the first
official computer bug a real-life moth
that found its way onto the number 70
relay of the harvard mark ii aiken relay
calculator today computer programmers
create their own bugs but that wouldn't
be possible without the help of a modern
code editor i wanted to find out which
code editor is best in the 2020s so i
tried to write a basic program with 10
different text editors and ides we'll
look at everything from basic command
line editors to the most advanced
cloud-based integrated development
environments we'll talk about the pros
and cons of each option and look at how
these tools have evolved over the last
50 years think about this
things like undo find and replace copy
and paste are all commonplace but back
in the 1960s they were revolutionary new
features made possible by the computer
screen and visual terminal eventually
they would replace punch cards where one
wrong keystroke meant you had to start
over from scratch the first editor we'll
look at is vi which was written by bill
joy and released in 1976. it's still a
standard tool on most linux distros to
this day so to use it all you have to do
is type vi into the terminal what's most
interesting is that it's a keyboard
based editor the mouse doesn't do
anything useful that's because the mouse
didn't go mainstream until the apple
macintosh came out in 1984 january 24th
apple computer will introduce macintosh
and you'll see why 1984 won't be
like 1984. but do you really need a
mouse to code efficiently in vi if you
start typing nothing will happen
initially that's because to write some
text you'll need to enter insert mode by
hitting the i key vi is a modal editor
which means the keys on your keyboard do
different things based on the mode
you're currently in in insert mode we
can add some actual code to the document
then hit escape to go back to command
mode and use the right quick command to
save the file to the disk when you get
used to it it can actually be very fast
to edit code this way for example to
delete an entire line of code i can hit
double d or 3 d to delete three lines at
once without needing to highlight the
entire thing with my mouse the hard part
is memorizing all the tricks to get
things done efficiently vi is nice and
simple but there are a lot of features
missing like syntax highlighting or the
ability to implement plugins to extend
its functionality around the same time
period another editor was being created
by guy steele at mit called emacs which
stands for editor macros like vi it's
primarily a keyboard based editor but
it's highly extensible and integrates
additional features like debuggers a
file manager terminal emulator music
player and anything else you can imagine
it's not just a text editor but a
full-blown integrated development
environment that means it can do a lot
more but it takes a lot more time to
configure on your part initially emacs
feels a little more user-friendly than
something like vi we can pull up a menu
that allows us to navigate the different
commands and it's a non-modal editor
which means we don't have to understand
what a bunch of different modes do
before using it however you will need to
use a bunch of modifier keys when typing
which could result in a gruesome injury
known as emax pinky at the same time
it's far from simple and has over 10 000
built-in commands that can be used to
create macros that customize the
experience and automate work now due to
the philosophical differences between
emacs and vi and the tribal nature of
developers two distinct factions have
emerged the cult of vi and the church of
emacs founded by high priest richard
stallman they've been waging war for
decades now and people take it very
seriously when you go to google to
search for vi it auto-corrects to emacs
or if you search for emacs it auto
corrects to bi in modern times though vi
based editors are much more popular and
that brings us to editor number three
vim or vi improved on the surface vim
feels almost identical to vi because
it's a superset of its core
functionality however it's much more
popular with developers using it as
their daily editor because it provides a
ton of other essential features like
syntax highlighting multi-level undo and
plugins to customize and extend its
functionality it's more developer
friendly and you can enter the vim tutor
command to learn the basics right now
it's kind of annoying at first but once
you have the basics down you'll find
that it keeps your fingers on the home
row of the keyboard which will gradually
improve your coding speed with a lot of
practice but it also does things like
code completion in a regular ide so it's
not just all about typing faster as you
start to learn it you'll see a lot of
people make jokes about not being able
to get out of them like developers in
the 60s were writing their own compilers
but developers today can't even exit
them without a soy latte and stack
overflow i don't want to beat off a dead
horse here so i'm not going to make one
of those jokes in this video vim was
created in 1991 making it older than
many viewers on this channel but not
everybody has been happy with its
evolution and that brings us to a
popular fork called neovim that came out
in 2015. first of all it's faster than
vim which is always a plus but one of
the ways you customize vim is with a
scripting language called vim script the
problem is that vimscript sucks
according to this one guy on hacker news
neovim has addressed this problem by
embedding lua as its scripting language
an extremely fast and proven language
that's also used by platforms like
roblox that's cool and all but what if
you don't want to spend years mastering
the art of vim another good option is
nano which is part of the gnu project
and came out in 1999. it's also a
keyboard based editor that you can
launch from the command line and unlike
vim it doesn't require modes and has a
far more gentle learning curve when you
open it you'll notice all the important
keybindings are right here at the bottom
most importantly it tells you control x
is how you exit so you don't have to
unplug your computer like you would with
vim
[Music]
it lacks the features you would need to
use it as a full-blown ide but is still
a great option available on most
machines to quickly edit a file from the
terminal at this point we've looked at
editors that mostly rely on a text user
interface but the majority of developers
today use editors that have a graphical
user interface one of the earliest
programs was notepad on windows which
came out in 1983. in fact the program
itself was designed to commercialize the
mouse for ms-dos a more modern version
for programmers is notepad plus plus
instead of using the keyboard to place
the cursor where you want to edit you
simply click there with the mouse or if
you want to highlight you click hold and
drag sounds obvious but in the early 80s
this was a feature that felt like going
into the metaverse today notepad plus
plus is not developed by microsoft but
it does feel very much like you're using
microsoft excel for writing code it
supports macros and plugins so you can
definitely use it as your primary
development environment next up we've
got a proprietary ide that's very near
and dear to my heart adobe dreamweaver i
haven't actually used it in years but
it's the tool that got me started in web
development it used to be extremely
popular but not so much anymore today
it's actually a very beautiful tool and
looks really nice while you're editing
code but at the same time feels overly
slow and complex like pretty much all
adobe software it's also pretty
antiquated with first class support for
jquery and bootstrap that's pretty sad
for a commercial product and if you're
paying to use dreamweaver in 2022 stop
it
get some help
mcdonald's wants you to give yourself a
chance there are far superior free
options in the modern world you've got
tools like sublime text brackets atom
which was killed recently
but the most popular lightweight editor
by far is visual studio code it has a
graphical user interface making it very
approachable for beginners but also has
a ton of built-in shortcuts that allow
you to do things quickly kind of like
text-based editors i actually have a
full course on fireship i o that breaks
down all my favorite techniques for
increasing productivity with vs code you
can support my work by enrolling in that
course or upgrading to a pro membership
young people from all over the globe are
joining up to fight for the future i'm
doing my part but an even bigger benefit
of vs code is the fact that it's popular
and has a huge extension ecosystem that
means if you're using some kind of
tooling that can benefit from additional
support like tailwind for example you're
pretty much guaranteed to have a vs code
extension which may not be the case on
other editors the application itself is
open source and built with electron
which is based on web technologies
making it easy to extend for web
developers although it does have a
reputation of being a memory hog the
editing experience can be very minimal
if you'd like and i usually go into zen
mode when writing code myself but at the
same time you can make it a full-blown
integrated development environment it
can edit files remotely on github
connect to your resources in the cloud
work with docker containers and so on
that's great and all but for many
platforms vs code may not be the optimal
choice if you're building ios apps
you'll likely want to use apple's
integrated development environment xcode
or for android apps google's android
studio or as we'll look at now visual
studio for microsoft's.net framework
this is a true integrated development
environment which is a comprehensive set
of tools for developing certain types of
apps like in this case desktop web and
server-side apps with dot-net it
provides powerful code completion
refactoring and debugging tools for its
core languages like c-plus plus and
c-sharp it may feel overwhelming at
first because there's all kinds of tools
and wizards that you're not going to
know how to use until you're balls deep
in a project when you get that deep
you'll be really glad to have tools like
that because otherwise you'll likely be
dealing with some half-assed open source
extension if you're lucky the bottom
line is that ides can be awesome when
you're committed to a specific platform
and that brings us to number 10
jetbrains a family of editors and ides
that many consider the gold standard for
writing code at a professional level
it's most well known for intellij for
java development but in this video we'll
look at webstorm for web development
although i use vs code today i've been a
happy jetbrains customer in the past but
that happiness comes at a cost of about
69 per year you can evaluate it with a
free trial and when you first open up
webstorm you'll notice things feel more
like a true ide as opposed to a minimal
text editor it has a wizard to guide you
through the setup of a new project
although this does feel pretty outdated
with options like meteor cordova and
angularjs version 1 which was retired a
few months ago if you're still using
angularjs version 1 you're only cheating
yourself out of the chance to find out
who you really can be once you're in the
project you should have pretty much
everything you need to hit the ground
running there's less of a need to
install a bunch of plugins one thing i
really appreciate about webstorm is its
code refactoring for example in a react
app we can click on a ui element and
easily extract it into its own named
component we can also do that in vs code
with extensions but it just feels way
more reliable in webstorm in webstorm
most of the features feel a little more
polished and reliable which is what you
would expect from a paid product what's
also interesting is that jetbrains is
coming out with a new editor called
fleet which will be more like a
competitor to vs code currently it's on
a close preview so i haven't been able
to try it but make sure you're
subscribed because as soon as it comes
out i'll drop a video we just looked at
10 different ways to edit code on your
machine but i want to finish up by
saying that we're entering an age where
code editors may become entirely
cloud-based like you can run vs code in
your browser right now by going to
vscode.dev then you've got github code
spaces where you can edit your code on
overpowered cloud hardware then you've
got tools like stack blitz that use
webassembly to run full stack web
applications in the browser the future
looks interesting but the most important
takeaway from this video is don't do
drugs thanks for watching and i will see
you in the next one